allez les Chéries on va passer au témoin
du jour c'est Aqua babe le blogueur
victime d'une violente agression à son
domicile hier matin vers 10h45 trois
individus cagoul ganté armé l'ont frappé
et menacé selon ce dernier cette
agression serait probablement liée à une
récente altercation avec l'influenceuse
poupette Kenza il va tout nous raconter
de cette histoire il possède des caméras
de surveillance la scène a donc été
filmée recap pu aquababe et son avocat
seront avec nous sur cette histoire
incroyable il va nous dire pourquoi il
pense que ce serait lié à une
altercation avec l'influenceuse popette
Ken Gill vous avez également enquêé et
tout le monde n'a parlé que de ça
aujourd'hui hein ah non mais c'est un
truc de fou il est avec nous aujourd'hui
B
voilà suivi par plus d'un million de
personnes sur Instagram aquababe se fait
un nom grâce à ses révélations autour de
la télééalité tu partages ta chirurgie
mais tu partages pas les risques tu dis
oui tout va bien alors que tu as une
infection mais aujourd'hui le jeune
homme affirme avoir été victime d'une
violente agression le blogueur aquababe
agressé chez lui hier matin des hommes
gantés cagoulés et armés se seraient
introduit à son domicile pour le frapper
et le menacer une agression qui serait
liée à un différent qui aurait eu lieu
avec l'influenceuse poupette Kenza on
veut me saboter toutes mes collabes et
tout et ça me met hors de moi si la
jeune femme affirme ne pas être
impliquée dans cette histoire le
blogueur a porté pleainte contreix et
poupé de Kenza aquababe victime d'une
violente agression à son domicile et
menacé avec une arme à feu il témoigne
ce soir dans
TPMP merci d'être avec nous aqu je le
sens on sent très très très très très
atteint et c'est bien normal hein on va
raconter ce qui s'est passé hier euh ça
va merci d'être là en tout cas parce que
je sais que c'est très compliqué pour
toi et et on pense on a pensé fort à toi
mon mon chéri ça va tu es en forme ou
bien tu es franchement non franchement
j'ai V tu sais que tu m'as dit que tu
pouvais même pas limite parler ouais je
su je en fait je suis encore sous le
choc je je suis encore sous le choc et
et avant de venir à tpnp j'ai j'ai dû
déposer mon dispositif de de caméras de
surveillance à la police pour éviter
entre guillemets que ce soit bah diffusé
sur les réseaux sociaux pour éviter
entre guillemets une espèce de représail
pour pas que ça retombe sur moi moi
j'aurais aimé qu'on qu'on puisse
diffuser bah quand même qu' que les
trois individus son sont venus quand
même chez moi armé gantter
cagoulé la police veut pas pour pas on
Travis l'enquête je respecte mais ça ça
me fait quand même du mal ouais alors on
va raconter ce qui s'est passé à quoi B
on va on va laisser euh euh d'ailleurs
euh ch raconter ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'on va pas te voilà il va nous dire ce
qui s'est passé aqub était chez lui hier
le matin et puis on sonne à la porte il
va ouvrir et là c'est il ouvre direct il
Touvre direct qumeoua en fait 20 minutes
avant 30 minutes avant mais je viis avec
ma meilleure pote donc 30 minutes avant
j'étais réveillée elle était réveillée
elle avait son rendez-vous chez la
prothésiste ongulaire donc je me suis
dit bon elle est partie 30 minutes 40
minutes après ça sonne à la je me suis
dit bon c'est c'est soit elle qui a dû
oublier un truc ou soit c'est la poste
donc j'ai pas eu le le réflexe et vu que
moi chez moi j'ai malheureusement j'ai à
ma porte il y a pas de Judas donc
directement je suis obligé d'ouvrir et
j'ai j'ai pas le réflexe et de de
vérifier à la fenêtre par exemple de ma
fenêtre parce que de ma fenêtre je peux
voir qui qui vient j'ai pas eu ce
réflexe là et j'ai depuis que j'habite
babas j'ai jamais eu le réflexe de me
dire oui je vais ouvrir la porte il va
se passer quelque chose donc j'ouvre
d'un coup je vois une
personne qui qui était qui était casquée
C goulé comme ça qui me dit à c'est
comment de parler de Poupet de Kenza
d'un coup dès que la personne a vu
j'étais entre guillemets seul il a dit
Go donc ces deux autres personnes qui
étaient cachées sont venu il m'a mis un
coup de cross au crâne il a sorti son
arm à feu et en mettant il poait son arm
à feu sur moi et il me disait ferme ta
gueule ferme ta gueule ferme ta gueule
donc du coup je me suis dit mais je vais
mourir dans mon SAS et le premier rlex
que j'ai eu c'est courir directement
dans les escaliers vu que mon ami il
dormait en haut dans la chambre je
criais Valentin Valentin Valentin et au
moment où je me mange le coup de cross
parce que je tis mon téléphone dans la
main comme à chaque fois vu que c'est ma
troisème main mon
téléphone il était déverrouillé et quand
j'ai vu que B c'était des individus et
c'était ni ma meilleure ni la poste je
vais pour composer le 17 sauf qu'il il
m'arrache mon téléphone et c'est là où
il met mon coup de
cross mon mon iPhone a fait un appel
d'urgence a établi un appel d'urgence au
112 pendant 24 secondes donc pendant 24
secondes il y avait une interlocutrice
qui disait allô allô allô qu'est-ce qui
se passe allô et dès que l'individu qui
m'a qui détenait l'arme avait mon
téléphone à raccroché quand il a senti
que bah je sais pas comment vous
expliquer mais quand j'ai couru pour
dire qu'entre guillemets Valentin aide
moi il se passe un truc de fou appelle
la police fait quelque chose c'est là où
ils sont tous partis dans les caméras de
surveillance on les voit courir et ils
ont relâché mon téléphone dans le sas
donc moi directement dans les caméras de
surveillance je sors je suis déboussolé
je me dis mais il s'est passé un truc de
fou donc on me voit comme ça
déambulé ensuite je rentre dans le sas
je récupère mon téléphone et c'est là où
en gros je vois que bah ils m'ont pas
volé mon téléphone et qu'ils ont pas
voulu le garder avec eux pour pas éviter
de se faire borner avec ou se faire
retrouver quoi franchement depuis ça je
suis je suis vraiment choqué gen
j'arrive même plus à ouvrir la porte
j'ai peur de la sonnette gen même mon à
uber j'ai peur tout à l'heure pour aller
au commissariat que pour demander les
caméras de surveillance je me retournis
gen encore la première fois quand j'ai
été agressé ça ça fait un bu sur les
réseaux sociaux mais ça a quand même
permis à d'autres personnes de de s'en
prendre à moi et de venir impuniment
chez moi m'attaquer carrément sur
Internet on remet en question
l'agression on dit oui c'est un coup de
buzz oui il a menti à son avocat non il
a déménagé carrément on dit oui c'est
mérité parce qu'il est homosexuel en
fait lire les mauvais commentaires comme
ça il y il y a énormément de messages
positifs je remercie vraiment tout le
monde pour ceux qui me soutient mais les
messages négatifs de personnes qui
pensent que c'est pour le buzz et que
j'ai carrément inventer tout ça ça me
meurtrrie ça me fait vraiment du mal ça
me choque je me dis mais comment les
gens peuvent croire et et dire que je
mens sur une agression aussi violente
genre il sait pas ça s'est passé avec
des preuves à l'appui au moment où où ça
s'est passé j'ai tout mis sur Twitter
pour éviter qu'entre guillemets les gens
disent oui il veut du buzz oui il veut
il veut gratter des vues j'ai pas besoin
de ça surtout une affaire comme ça ça
m'intéresse pas j'aurais préféré
carrément que ce soit un coup de buzz
parce que je suis choqué genre j'ai mal
au crânne par exemple ce matin quand je
suis parti à l'UMJ à à Argenteuil avais
rendez-vous à 11h j'avais super mal je
lu disais mais est-ce que c'est normal
qu' qu' m' mis un coup de cross mais
j'ai quand même mal à la mâchoire quand
je quand je mange ou quand j'ouvre la
bouche il dit ça duréit combien de temps
pour alors ça ça a duré franchement 15
20 secondes mais pour moi ça quoi il
voulait vraiment voulait vous faire peur
voulait mettre un coup de pression c'est
quoi c'est ça pour pour moi pour moi oui
c'était vraiment on a essayé de
m'intimider mais c'est ça
ouais je me
dis imaginons ces personnes là ils
étaient vraiment déterminés et que
j'aurais pas crié ou que je j'aurais pas
ça auà de ça c'est c'est un traumatisme
pour toi je je me dis mais en fait j'ai
eu peur d'une balle perdue sincèrement
j'ai eu peur de mour arrivé là déjà on
le voit tu es traumatisé non je je suis
vraiment choqué qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en fait al c'est quoi l'histoire
parce qu'on parle tu dis qu'il t'ont dit
il t'ont parlé de poupette Kenza c'est
c'est c'est quoi l'histoire qui veut
raconter pour nous nous moi j'avais pas
suivi cette affaire donc c'est c'est
quoi c'est quoi l'histoire entre vous
deux al l'ho l'histoire déjà elle est
simple simplement la raison de notre
présence ici c'est déjà effectivement
comme le dit mon client monsieur Zitouni
expliquer que c'est bien réel il y a
beaucoup de gens il subit du
cyberhcèlement il l'a dit qu'il ferait
le buzz qu'il chercherait les followers
ce n'est pas le cas ce qui s'est passé
est extrêmement grave et c'est pour ça
qu'on est ici peut-être dans un état où
aquab mon client monsieur zouni n'est
pas dans l'état de le faire mais pour
autant on a besoin de le montrer la
deuxième chose c'est dire attention
attention parce que ce qu'il se passe
sur les réseaux peuvent conduire à des
catastrophes ça c'est la le prologue
ensuite sur l'histoire avec Poupet de
Kenza moi je vais être très clair ce
soir et c'est la même chose pour Aqua
Bab on accuse personne on accuse
personne il y a une enquête qui est
diligentée pour des faits qui sont
extrêmement graves il y a plusieurs
piste on verra ce que les enquêteurs
décident de poursuivre ou pas pour
autant on a transmis effectivement des
éléments qu'on peut trouver presque
saisissant troublant de la part de cette
poupette Kenza à savoir en amont de de
ce qui est arrivé à Monsieur zituni des
images et des menaces de mort on a porté
plainte pour les menace de mort des
images de son domicile qui ont été
transmis sur les réseaux sociaux mais
aussi et c'est là aujourd'hui ce qu'on
apprend et c'est et c'est là où on est
stupéfait poupé de Kenza a affirmé sur
les réseaux sociaux avoir été l'auteur
de message vers d'autres personnes pour
trouver l'adresse
d'aquabab dès le samedi on naccuse
absolument personne on verra si elle
peut être trouvée comme commanditaire ou
pas on verra ce qui est sûr c'est que le
fait de trouver et de vouloir chercher
l'adresse d'aquababe après un conflit
qui était le leur un conflit mineur un
conflit sur un placement de produit
vouloir chercher son adresse ça semble
au minimum inquiétant je c'est
simplement ça sur popet Kenza comme ça
c'est dit on accuse personne on est
circonspect il y a plusieurs enquêtes
qui sont menées et aussi et surtout et
je m'arrête là le fait qu'effectivement
quand c'est quand ces gens g arrivent il
parl de Poupet de Kenza est-ce que ça
veut dire que Poupet de Kenza les a
envoyé non certainement pas certainement
pas elle est présumé innocente elle si
ça se trouve et je l'espère et on
l'espère rien à voir avec ça par contre
ce que ça prouve peut-être c'est que
quand on natise la haine sur les réseaux
sociaux et je m'arrête là parce que le
FBI veut parler il aura peut-être la
solution mais
sérieusement qu on accuse des choses
quand on menace de mort ça des conséquen
bien sûr exactement exactement g
j'aimerais queon explique pour les
téléspectateurs alors il faut rappeler
que poupette Kenza ni tout lien avec
l'agression mais il y a un contentieux
entre aquabeb et Poupette Kenza puisque
aquabeb depuis quelques temps avait
dénoncé les pratiques les pratiques
commerciales de Poupet de Kenza
notamment le fait qu'elle continue euh
des placements de produits euh alors que
elle était avec son enfant à l'hôpital
on est d'accord là-dessus donc aquabeb
avait dénoncé ça